バッハ
こんにちははじめしゃちょーね今日もよく等学校が終わって家に帰ってきました
じゃあ今日も頑張ったよ俺相当な寒いんであんまり外に出たくない
そしてバンクで学校練ってるから朝ずひくという中で頑張って学校に行ってきましたが
今日も一緒に地味なをつくれなかった
俺も我慢画面の部コーナーでも頑張った
ホント皆ガンマーさんみんなよく頑張ったよ
所沢頑張ったよおっチラッ保存ねドトール今僕はですねモンスターハンタークロスに
本当にはまっててもうね今すごいが負けますもうねぇ
恋してるんですよもうモンスターハンターのことしか今ちょっと考えれないでベルまで
ちょっとついてて辛勝に良くないと思っている抹茶
&学校に行ったり鼻立つしなければちゃんとやってるんですけどもそれ編時間全部
モンスターハントしてモンスターあんたを開けレベルまでやりこむ
23日すればたぶんこの波やサルと思うんですけども手狭でもうネ申となんだろう
よろしくねはいここで楽しいんですけど持ったねそういう感じなんでちょっとに卒論と
かも色々あるんですけどもなんだかちゃんねススメと言うまで今日に計算して動いて
んでそれでもまあ3超ハマってるんで買っちゃったわけですよモンスターハンター
スタンダードモデル+それがモンスターハンターのフィギュアが入ってるやつをですね
6種類入ってるみたいなんですけども全部買っちゃいました
高木強 fick 800円だってやばい八郎と始終発五線譜んじゃないかコンビニで
発見で別件がも操作ないと思うんでかなり期待しております
全部倒してボーダースパートをすべて集めるとクリア版のフィギュア1体完成しますと
いうわけでこれで全部出ればって話だよひょっとしたら同じように入ってるかもしん
ないあそれはないかなクリア版のフィギュアが一体完成するかもしれないんでちょっと
楽しみですねこれ花弁のかなぁ褒めたら行為んですけどとりあえずちょっと全部開けて
いきましょう
もう一度一人クエストはクリアしたんでライブ落ち着いているんですけども
うさぎですもう人に頑張れは5オンス半端クロスが一通り終わるんで再コメです
大デュエル re
尻尾のパートフレックで発がとりあえずで投げていきましょう
ハヌガールズだいろいろうんうんん
あんま喋んないようにしようが今日これ被ってないで多分このままいくと
やっぱちゃんと被らないようになってもそうなった後全部されましたちょっとひとつ
ずつれていました
で待ってかっこよすぎて閉めるじゃあまず最初に当たった料理ですから見ていき
ましょう
やばいやばいやばいうおーこんな感じですコマ系やがちゃってこれかっこよすぎ
ショッピたきたきたきたはいこういう感じです埋まってめちゃんとかっけーぞああこう
いう感じになっておりますどうで
そうかこの学校さあね本当にね買ってよかったって思うねやって生地の場でと作って
いきますまあこいつはもうこのまま出来上がってるのかメインキャラクターメイン
モンスターみたいな感じで
この県ねハンターをね行くの保育のも攻撃してくる
これもすっごい凝った造りだこの鱗の感じわかっ消えた次ナルガクルガ行けますあの
ちょっと足が売れちゃってるってかもほぼ浮いてるなぁ種
保育腕の力だそんなに腕力はないはずなんですけどもできましたナルガクルガでござい
ます今回はりと音なんか
雑魚敵レベルのポジションになってしまってたんですけれどもこれもなかなか細かい
ところまでできておりますし次がムートいきます何でもこれも凝ってるはやばいは凝っ
てるコってるなんてが部ではないんでがメジャーなかなゆまでがんつぁ亀ちゃん
した場合がムードでこんな感じでございます何か薄汚いだ
なんて言えないんですけどまんぼすっていうかぞうさんなんですよ顔がもうこの炭素だ
がちょっと大変だったもんさーですねはい
ガーネットです火をレイヤーですまあこれもすぐ作れそう
もう余裕のゆっ追加でしょこれ技名やって風のポーズ毎回必ずいるから倒す方法が
わかってるんですよ
こいつとさっき言ったこの後ろのリオレウスとこの後音レイヤーが夫婦
なんですよハネ感が凄いムーン
ちょっ
気持ち悪いぐらいかなここが夫婦なんでここを一緒にさせているだけよ
優しいはず目じゃあそして最後はコチラ逆ですですわぁや逆ですねおいら多分一番好き
なモンスターなんですよ海の竜カーもう見るからに海にそうでしょ
海にいるんすやすやそうだ ok よいいっ
かっこいいはイケメンや意見だこれどう空子
な顔になるホラー俺もこんな顔に生まれたかったよ
いややっぱりやめとこはやばいちょっと満足でき仕上がりな者ベンしてこれはいやー
みなさん1球目ですよまずでどうなってですかこれもうね全員かっこいい
はいあーなんか全体間に混獲てすごい感動しました
花に入ったよアイディア義理母だったでしょうかあのモンスターハンターがわからない
人から見ても付けながらリアルですごいなっていうのが伝わったのかもしれない返書
上がりまくりんこバックスなどで大スター版たんの音モンスターの好きな人を買ってみ
てはいかがでしょうか
らゲートですがやっぱね一番カッコイイしねボーナスパンとまとめてできるあの
スペシャルフィギュアがあるんですけどもそちらがこれです完成しました
もうちょっと大阪に頑張って行きたいと思います今日の動画わー
自己満足
par